trotzdem die Frage an Sie Herr lambu wie
würden sie es machen wir haben jetzt
diese
Situation er kämpft auf seinem Posten V
teteberg kämpft auf ihren Posten Robin
Alexander schreibt erfolgreiche Bücher
darüber die getriebenen der bestzeller
zur flüchtlingskrise 25 216 und wir das
Land streitet seit Jahren über die Frage
des richtigen Umgangs wir wollen
einerseits gute Menschen sein die Leute
nicht im Stich lassen und auf der
anderen Seite wissen wir es
gibt Kapazitätsgrenzen wie würden sie es
machen
im Grunde genommen macht es uns
Australien seit 2014 vor die hatten ein
ähnliches Problem große Insel austr
frühzeitig reagiert you will not make
Australia home sie haben das
durchgezogen und es sind dann ein Jahr
später bereits kaum noch Migranten
gekommen und ich fürchte wir werden am
Ende des
Tages auf dieses australische Modell
gehen müssen okay aber Australien ist
ist ein Kontinent okay aber man könnte
auch sagen ist eine sehr weit abgelegene
Insel da kommt man gar nicht so leicht
hin da ist Kontrolle relativ einfach und
was die Australier gemacht haben war
brutal das wissen sie auch
ähm klassische Einwanderungsländer wie
Australien USA und Kanada sind knallhart
beim Thema Migration denn die haben
viele Hunderte von Jahren Erfahrung
knallhart war in Australien wirklich
pushbacks Schiffe irgendwo raus auf
irgendwelche Inseln se zu wie er klar
kommt das war das Thema ja würden sie
auch so machen in letzter
Konsequenz wird uns nichts anderes übrig
bleiben das heißt sie würden sie was
würden Sie machen konkret wie würden sie
es machen würden Sie sagen okay dann
sehen wir zu wie Leute im Boote steigen
wir sehen auch zu wie Leute auf dem
mittelmeeher Trinken und dann bauen wir
einfach so hohe Zäune
oder schieben sie zurück ins Wasser bis
es aufhört würden sie es so machen also
wir möchten von der AFD niemand er
trinken lassen wir sehen auch die Not
der Menschen oder die Hoffnung auf ein
besseres Leben dass sie nach Europa
treibt aber es ist auch eines klar wir
vertreten als Politiker die Interessen
der Bürger dieses Landes ob mit oder
ohne Migrationshintergrund und nicht die
Interessen der Menschen die nach
Deutchland kommen wollen das verstehe
ich will nur verstehen wie sie es machen
ich habe die Frage Vau toteberg auch
nicht erspart ich kann sie ihn auch
nicht ersparen ich will nur wissen wie
machen sie das ich halte Versprechen ist
immer wir kriegen das in Griff und ihr
die Altparteien oder die Elite oder was
auch immer dann so das Wording ist ihr
kriegt das All nicht Griff wie schaffen
Sie es es gibt keine einfachen Lösungen
denn dieses Problem hat man sich 8 Jahre
entwickel lass das ist jetzt der
Baustein die fluskel MA ich füh es ja
gerade aus und
ähm in letzter Konsequenz
ähm brauchen wir in der Tat europäische
Lösungen aber diese
umverteilungsdiskussion die H ich jetzt
seit Jahren es gibt eine ganze Menge von
Ländern in Europa die wollen keine
Umverteilung die werden da auch nie
mitmachen sondern wir brauchen eine EUR
Lösung in dem Sinne dass wir dafür
sorgen dass die Leute gar nicht mehr
kommen und wir haben eben über
Australien gesprochen wir haben auch das
Mittelmeer und wir haben hier eben über
pushbacks gesprochen ähm wie hat wie hat
man das denn früher gemacht früher gab
es an der afrikanischen Küste Staaten
die dafür gesorgt haben dass die Leute
überhaupt nicht in Bote steigen können
und deswegen hatten wir früher dieses
Problem auch nicht na ja früher hatten
wir andere technische Möglichkeiten oder
nichtmöglichkeiten früher gab es eine
andere Form von Kommunikation früher gab
es weniger Bevölkerungswachstum früher
gab es diese Art von schleuserwesen
nicht noch mal ganz konkret sie sagen es
braucht diese europäische Lösung Herr
Lambro wir können sie wollen sie ne Chu
sie sind doch die AFD sie wollen doch
die EU abschaffen nein wir wollen die EU
reformieren und auf einen Kern
zurückführen Herr höcke woll sie sterben
lassen das habe ich zuletzt vernommen
Herr höcke hat gesagt wenn sie es jetzt
populistisch zuspitzen wollen dann muss
diese EU sterben damit Europa leben kann
er hat also a zugespitzt und B auch klar
gesagt dass er ein positives Ziel hat
nämlich ein Europa was funktioniert ein
Europa der
vaterländerin was der der Vaterländer in
ihrem Bundestagswahlprogramm stand dass
sie die EU abschaffen wollen und in
europawahlprogramm was jetzt aktuell ist
haben sie den Satz rausgenommen weil sie
einmal alle darauf angesprochen haben
und da steht aber noch der Neuaufbau
aber bevor man was neu aufbaut muss es
ja kaputt sein also sie sind in den
letzten Bundestagswahlkampf gezogen mit
die Abschaffung der EU und wenn die
Journalisten sie gefragt haben sie immer
gesagt haben wir nicht so gemeint mm ist
aber im Wahlprogramm der Satz und da
müssen sie auch zu stehen es gab eine
Debatte auf dem eu-parteitag der AFD in
Magdeburg und die ist von den Kräften
entschieden worden die gesagt haben wir
streben eine Reformierung der EU an wir
sehen den Satz in Buch drin ich kann ih
den Vorlesen lass mich ger von Herrn LZ
unterbrechen aber ich würde hier gerne
Ausreden wenn ich ein sie dürfen das
Reden sie aus und währendessen sucht
Robin Alexander Satz
Bundestagswahlprogramm für
Bundestagswahl 2021 wir halten einen
Austritt Deutschlands aus der EU und die
Gründung einer neuen europäischen
Wirtschafts und Interessengemeinschaft
für notwendig also sie wollen austreten
Bundestagswahlprogramm wenn sie mich
ausreden lassen kann ich ihn erklären
was die aktuelle Position der AFD ist
wir wollen seit wann aktuell also das
gilt nicht mehr hier wir haben ein
eu-wahlprogramm und die EU-Wahl steht im
Juni nächsten Jahres an und wir wollen
einen weiteren Versuch machen die EU zu
reformieren wir sehen dass hier ein
Bürokratiemonster entsteht wir sehen
dass die EU beim Schutz der Außengrenzen
dramatisch versagt dass es einen
Reformbedarf gibt wird keiner bestreiten
können die ultima ratio wenn das nicht
gelingen sollte ja da gebe ich Ihnen
recht ist dann der Ausstieg von
Deutschland aus der EU aber bevorzugt
wollen wir diese Reformierung schaffen
Europa auf den kernedanken
zurückführen weil wir gerade so viel
jetzt über börn höcke sprechen und
diesen Satz und dieses EU
europawahlprogramm wir hören einfach mal
kurz rein ich glaube wir haben das
Vorliegen vielleicht können die Kollegen
das einmal kurz zuspielen
und
danach klopfen wir das einfach mal
ab ja ich bin kein kein Freund der
Europäischen Union das ist eine
globalisierungsinstanz und Agentur die
vor allen Dingen den den deutschen
Nettozahlern das Geld aus der Tasche
zieht ohne dass wir ein großen Nutzen
davon haben die die vielfältige
europäische Kultur gleichschaltet und
wenn sie von mir mal eine populistische
Aussage hören wollen dann kann ich ihn
das ein eine Aussage zusammenpacken
diese EU muss sterben damit das wahre
Europa leben kann das da bin ich
überzeugt
ja das kann man nicht missverstehen ne
ich habe es ja eben erklärt und ich habe
auch ganz klar gesagt dass sich andere
Strömungen durchgesetzt haben und ich
halte es hier mit Alice Weidel und Tino
kopaller und die stehen für diesen Kurs
dass wir reformieren wollen und ich
glaube auch dass wir im Juni
2024 dass wir ein anderes EU-Parlament
kriegen und dass da durchaus Mehrheiten
sind für für diesen reformierungsprozess
wie wie geht's ihnen sie kommen ja auch
aus dem kontrolling ne sie haben ja BWL
studiert ich bin Diplomkaufmann und habe
im Marketing im Vertrieb und im
kontrollingaben so genau ist auch
überhaupt eine interessante Vita ne sie
waren noch mal in der SPD ich war
anderthalb Jahre in der SPD während des
studiumsn war das wann war das in
Münster Anfang der 90er Jahre okay und
sind warum in die SPD rein es gab damals
diese öffentliche Debatte über
Politikverdrossenheit und ich habe mir
gedacht da kannst du was gegen tun indem
du auch in einer Partei mitmachst okay
wollten arbeiten ja konstruktiv an an
Lösungen Leute davon überzeugen dass
Politik eine gute Sache ist und dann
sind sie wieder raus und Jahre später in
die AFD rein ja ich bin nach anderthalb
Jahren raus weil zumindestens in Münster
die SPD sich damals weitgehend mit sich
selber beschäftigt hat und das ist für
mich nicht Politik ich habe die SPD bis
2012 weiter gewählt dann wusste ich
allerdings nicht mehr wen ich wählen
soll als Diplomkaufmann habe ich diese
Politik der euror Rettung sehr kritisch
gesehen schon seit z 2008 und in der
Situation kam dann Ende 2012 das Gerücht
auf da gibt's eine neue Partei die sieht
das auch alles sehr kritisch und dann
bin ich als einer der ersten auch
Mitglied geworden und sind dann in die
AFD rein als sie noch sousagen die
eurokritische Partei war und deswegen
ich erwähne das deswegen weil ich mE
interessieren würde er sagt ja ich muss
jetzt mal was populistisch zuspitzen er
hat aber vorher schon zweimal
populistisch har zugespitzt man sagt da
wird alles gleichgeschaltet kein schöner
Begriff in dem Zusammenhang übrigens in
Europa so eine gleichschaltungs ent und
er sagt wir sind da große große Zahler
in diese EU als Deutschland und haben
kaum was davon wie geht's hin wenn sie
sowas hören na ja wir sind der größte
Nettozahler wir sind auch das größte
Land in Europa ja dennoch bleibt die
Aussage von
höer geht um den zweiten Teil obwohl wir
kaum was davon haben wir haben etwas
davon aber das Gefühl bei vielen
Menschen ist das Gefühl ja das Gefühl
und es geht ih ums Gefühl nein es geht
mir nicht nur ums Gefühl sie sind sie
eine gefühlspartei oder nein aber man
muss halt auch den Willen der Mehrheit
der Bevölkerung zur Kenntnis nehmen und
äh knapp eine Entschuldigung sie sind
sie sind sie sind Betriebswirt und
verstehen auch was von Volkswirtschaft
nehme ich an also dieses Land hat doch
wie kein anderes von dieser Europäischen
Union profitiert wir wollen den
gemeinsamen Binnenmarkt ja auch erhalten
aber wissen Sie also ja oder nein stimmt
das oder stimmt das nicht wie war die
Frage dass wir profitiert haben davon
wie kaum ein anderes Land in Europa ja
die Frage ist nur ob wir in
ausreichendem Maße von profitiert haben
lassen m aber haben wir profitiert oder
nicht wir haben profitiert aber nicht im
ausreichenden Maße und ich möchte jetzt
einen Gedanken gerade ausführen warum
ist denn Großbritannien aus der EU raus
weil die wirtschaftlichen Überlegungen
eine ganzagen die sich heute auch eine
ganz andere Frage überlagert hat nämlich
die Masseneinwanderung und ich glaube
dass es hier eine Mehrheit gab weil die
Bevölkerung gesagt haben dass das
möchten wir so innerhalb der EU nicht
weitermachen und Großbritannien sucht ja
jetzt nach Lösung als einzelnes Land und
denkt auch über Länder in Afrika nach wo
man dann entsprechend die Leute gekommen
sind hinausfliegt genauso wie Australien
also a wird in England kein ausgeflogen
ist noch überhaupt kein einziger Mensch
ausgeflogen worden zweitens gibt's
gerade in England sehr viel auch
gewollte Einwanderung weil sie ein
riesiges fachkräfteprblem haben und
dritter Punkt die Leute sind belogen
worden die merken es doch jetzt die
Engländer was passiert ist mit dem
Austritt aus der EU zwar für dieses Land
nicht gut also das BR in landsprodukt
die Veränderung die relative zum zum
Feuer ist in Großbritannien wesentlich
besser als in Deutschland Robin
alexander hat gerade den Kopf
geschüttelt für mich ist das total
schwierig ich bin ja Journalist und die
AFD schimpft immer nehmt uns ernst ne so
und ist ja auch okay sind ja eine
gewählte Partei nur wenn ich ihnen ihr
Programm vorlese dann sagen Sie das gilt
nicht und wenn der landz ihn den hörke
vorspielt dann sagen Sie das gilt auch
nicht und das macht es echt schwierig
das habe ich das habe ich gar nicht so
gesagt ich habe klar darauf verwiesen
dass wir ein aktuelles Programm und
haben und das ist das
eu-wahlprogramm nicht das
Bundestagswahlprogramm und zu börn höcke
habe ich klar gesagt wie ich das
verstehe und dass ich es hier mit Alis
Weidel und Tino kopalla halte und dass
ich dieser Bereich auch durchgesetzt hat
auf aber her das Bundestagswahlprogramm
gilt doch für die
Legislaturperiode und da sind wir doch
gerade das ist ihr Programm das gilt und
da steht drin Austritt außer EU so und
dann können sie doch nicht verlangen
dass ich als Journalist sage sie haben
so schöne Augen das war wohl versehen
mit dem Programm sie haben auch eine
Forderung mal gehabt keine Atomwaffen
mehr in Deutschland eine klassisch linke
Forderung wo man sich fragt ist es ihr
Programm was ist mit der NATO und und
und und so könnte man das durchgehen von
A bis Z und das macht es schwierig weil
sie sind sauer die Journalisten nehmen
uns nicht ernst aber wenn wir in die
Details gehen ja dann alles nicht so
gemeint und anders und fragen Sie Frau
weitel und das muss ich jetzt auch mal
ihnen spiegeln das macht es sch erig sie
journalistisch zu bearbeiten wie alle
anderen na ja als Journalist sollten Sie
dann aber auch nicht ignorieren dass wir
jetzt ein eu-wahlprogramm haben aber das
habe ich doch des Bundestags
Wahlprogramm gilt für die
Legislaturperiode oder das von Frau
Teuteberg das von ihm von allen das
eu-wahlprogramm gilt für die EU-Wahl ist
noch gar nicht über welches Thema reden
wir jetzt eigentlich aber schau
sieade über Europa ist keine kleine
Frage also ob Deutschland in der EU ist
oder nicht ist nun wirklich für also
wenn wir da wackeln würden hätten wir
wirtschaftliche Probleme die ganz anders
wer schonüren sofort W nur einmal das
Argument sozusagen noch mal klar
zuspitzen also wir kommen sie sagen wir
reden über Migration das Thema von dem
sie profitieren will ich in dem
Zusammenhang gar nicht sagen es ist ein
drängendes Thema ist ein großes Thema
und wir brauchen seriöse Antworten auf
dieses große auf dieses große Thema
andreas lichert
hat von der Erfindung der klimakippunkte
gesprochen mm ist richtig ne sehen sie
auch so die klimakipppunkte sind heiß
diskutiert ob das wirklich
zutriff oder ob das eine Überspitzung
ist genau mir geht mir geht's um was
anderes mir geht's um ich ich fü noch
mal ganz kurz aus und sagt dann trotzdem
sollen ich zitiere Billionen risikoarmes
Steuergeld ausgegeben werden wegen
dieser klimakippunkte und sagt dann das
erklärt sehr viel besser die plötzlich
aufkeimende Begeisterung der
internationalen hoch Finanz und
Großindustrie als tatsächliche Liebe zum
Klimaschutz
mhm das Wort
Hochfinanz würden würden sie das
benutzen dieses Wort ich kannte die
Vergangenheit dieses Begriffes nicht das
war im Rahmen einer ähm einer Debatte
zum Stand der Energiewende in Hessen
Große Anfrage der SPD jeder hatte 10
Minuten Redezeit und Andreas lichert hat
in dieser zehnminütigen Rede einmal
Hochfinanz gesagt daraufhin gab es dann
Empörung bei den Grünen ich habe das
während der Debatte gogelt und wenn sie
auf Wikipedia gehen steht dort ganz klar
dieser Begriff hat eine problematische
Vergangenheit aber spätestens seit
Beginn der Finanzkrise 2008 wird er ganz
allgemein verwendet das dann Andreas
lichard ans Revert zu heften ist wieder
nicht fair sondern es ist framing dieses
Wort finden Sie im Spiegel das finden
Sie im Handelsblatt es wird Spiegel als
Hochfinanz es wird seit 200 allgemein
verwendet es hat eine problematische
Vergangenheit andreas lichert hat es
genau zweimal benutzt ein einziges Mal
in dieser Rede und einen Tag später um
auch noch mal ein Zeichen zu setzen dass
er sich nicht den Mund verbieten lässt
mit Begriffen die eben stand heute in
Ordnung sind und danach hat er es aber
auch nicht mehr benutzt aber ist das ist
das ich meine Hochfinanz ne ist das das
Codewort sozusagen für die große
jüdische
Weltverschwörung und das ich bin mir
sicher dass er sich den bewusst war
deswegen hat das ja auch genauso benutzt
genauso ist es auch eingesetzt ich muss
widersprechen ich denke dass er es sich
nicht bewusst war und ich kannte
z.B macht Lamb also wenn ich das mal
also ich hör mir das jetzt seit ein paar
Minuten an aber das ist genau das wie
sie Verfahren sie haben hochprematische
Personen in ihren in ihren rein in ihrer
Partei sie haben selber gesagt die
Kokettieren mit historischen vergleichen
die nicht in Ordnung sind weit weg von
dem was hier demokratischer Konsens in
diesem Staat war und immer noch ist Gott
sei Dank aber sie sind s so unterwegs
dass sie sind durchgesegelt genau mit
diesem gemäßigten Ton mit dieser Fassade
durch den
hessenwahlkampf sie habeni rein genau
die Leute die sie nee ne sie haben genau
die Leute die aber die codeworts
benutzen
genau will nicht unterstellen dass es
Fassade ist ich würde aber gerne
erwidern ja ich will nur sagen ich halte
das nicht für was sie angeht nicht für
Fassade ich ich nehme ihn das ab aber zu
bestreiten dass es dieses dieses Spiel
ist dieses es Zündel mit genau diesen
problematischen Wörtern was was der Mann
der demnächst für Sie nach Europa gehen
soll genauso spielt ich ich finde wir
sollten uns ein bisschen ehrlicher
machen sie sind doch die Partei der
Anständigen wir sollten uns doch nicht
hier gegenseitig irgendeinen vom Pferd
erzählen sondern ehrlich sein
Miteinander ist doch Quatsch ist doch
Quatsch zu zu sagen das ist nicht so
gemeint das war dem nicht klar der Kah
ist ein aufrechter Demokrat der will
auch Europa nicht
abschaffen dieses dieses ganze
Geschwurbel über Männer sind recht
und unsere Vorfahren haben sich nicht
schuldig gemacht und so weiter das
spielt doch die ganze Zeit mit genau
diesem Thema warum machen sie damit ich
würde kurz hier noch erwidern weil ich
sehe es genau andersrum wir werden
ständig geframt das ist kein framing
wenn sie so sprechen ist das eine
eindeutige Anspielung das sind
eindeutige Worte die dort wir sind bei
dem Beispiel mit dem Begriff Hochfinanz
da kann jeder Zuschauer jetzt googlen
und auf Wikipedia lesen ob das stimmt
was ich gerade gesagt habe das
spätestens seit 2008 das allgemein
verwendet wird das nehmen sie nicht zur
Kenntnis und framen Andreas lichert und
dieses Spiel ich bin ja seit Anfang an
dabei geht seit 2013 mit der AFD wissen
Sie ich kenne nichts Radikaleres in
diesem Land als die Politik der
Bundesregierung unter Angela Merkel und
Olaf Scholz in Bezug auf die
Masseneinwanderung und das ist der Grund
warum viele Leute sagen wir machen
dieses framing nicht mehr mit wir
durchschauen das wir wähen die AFD weil
wir wollen nicht dass dieses Politik
Versagen der anderen Parteien so
weitergeht wissen Sie die
Masseneinwanderung hat kein Problem
geschaffen aber sie verschärft
dramatisch eine ganze Menge
gesellschaftspolitischer Probleme und
wir haben hier anfangs darüber geredet
dass wir diese Sendung in drei Jahren
noch mal ausstrahlen können nein das
können wir nicht denn wir sind in einer
massiven Überforderung sie haben gerade
ganz klar gesagt wie sehr sie an der
Belastungsgrenze sind mit den
Kapazitäten in D Jahren das werden sie
aber nicht lösen keine Antwort drauf
geliefert nicht inelben Situation sie
werden keine Antwort darf wie sie das
lösen wollen ich habe ganz klar gesagt
wir werden auf das australische Modell
geh die Europäische Union sie abschaffen
warten sie ich hatte eben noch was sagen
wollen das kann ich jetzt hier gut
einfügen ich wollte folgendes sagen es
fehlt seit
2015 der politische Wille dieses Problem
lösen zu follen stattdessen prügelt man
die AFD die seit 2015 immer wieder auf
Dinge hingewiesen hat jetzt werden
teilweise Ideen der AFD umgesetzt für
die man uns jahrelang prügelt hat
letzter Satz ich halte es mit dem
Altbundespräsidenten Joachim Gauk der
hat ganz klar auch davon gesprochen wir
brauchen eine neue Entschlossenheit und
wir werden Gesetze ändern müssen wenn
wir das lösen wollen dann werden wir in
letzter Konsequenz auf das australische
Modell gehen müssen und die politische
Bereitschaft dazu besteht nicht in der
Bevölkerung allerdings wächst sie weil
die Bevölkerung erlebt wie diese
Auswirkung der Masseneinwanderung in
ihren Alltag eindringen sie erleben das
Framing der AFD und sie schauen dann
irgendwann aber mal genauer hin und
sehen dass das so gar nicht zutrifft und
dann wählen Sie uns z.B auch die Leute
die sehr jung sind das hat mich nicht
überrascht wir erleben das in vielen
Schulklassen da wird eine Stunde lang
auf den afder drauf gehauen und das
machen viele junge Leute nicht mit und
kommen dann danach oft zu dem afdler und
reden mit denen noch 10 20 30 Minuten
weil sie das auffühlt wie mit unseren
Leuten umgegangen
wird also das Bundesamt für
Verfassungsschutz hat glaube 22 noch mal
im Mai festgehalten Hochfinanz ist ein
hochproblematischer Begriff und ist
einer der in einem ganz bestimmten
Kontext steht ein klar antisemitischer
code will das nur noch mal fürs
Protokoll sagen
ähm Zuwanderung weil sie immer wieder
drauf abheben Erbo und sie weisen ja
auch zurecht darauf hin dass wir da ein
Thema haben wie würden sie es machen ich
ich habe mir mal ihr Programm angeschaut
illegale Einwanderung stoppen Sie m und
schieben ausreisepflichtige sofort ab
wie machen sie das wenn da Leute vor
ihnen stehen die
sagen meine Identität ist unklar sie
wissen gar nicht wohin sie den
eigentlich abschieben sollen welches
Land überzeugen sie davon den
aufzunehmen sie ihn ich wäre froh wenn
wir die 300.000 Menschen die im Moment
ausreisepflichtig sind abschieben
könnten dazu brauchen wir entsprechend
die Einstufung als sichere
Herkunftsländer wir brauchen die
Vereinbarung mit den Ländern dass sie
diese Menschen zurücknehmen wir brauchen
mehr abschiebegefängnisse wir brauchen
mehr Personal aber vor allen Dingen
brauchen wir den politischen Willen und
den sehe ich nicht sie haben jetzt den
politischen Willen wie machen sie es sie
stecken Leute ins Gefängnis oder was
machen sie nein wir sind ein Rechtsstaat
und die AFD ist eine
rechtsstaatsptei es gibt hier wie machen
sie das wohin schieben Sie jemanden ab
dessen Identität sie z.B nicht
zweifelsfrei klären können wie machen
sie das das ist ein riesen Problem und
es gibt keine einfachen Lösungen aber in
den letzten a Jahren gab es nicht mal
den Polti Willen das anzugehen sondern
ich höre dann immer wie eben auch wir
müssen das auf europäischer Lösung
umverteilen obwohl die Politiker die das
sagen ganz genau wissen dass das nicht
klappen wird das Beste ist wenn die
Menschen gar nicht erst
herkommen aber sie sie haben gerade sie
haben gerade gesagt vorin wir brauchen
eine europäische Lösung am in letzter
Konsequenz werden wir das nicht böse
aber das ist genau sozusagen der Satz
den ich jedem um die Ohren hauen würde
wenn er ihn einfach hier so ausspricht
weil wir alle wissen dass ist schwierig
mit der europäischen lös wenn sie sagen
da fehlt der politische Wille dann müss
doch was anderes was besseres was
schlaueres einfallen als die europäische
Lösung wir können als Deutschland eine
ganze Menge Dinge machen ein paar Sachen
habe ich gesagt aber wissen Sie da muss
auch der politische Wille dafür da sein
dass an den vielen kleinen
Stellschrauben gedreht werden kann in
letzter Konsequenz haben wir mit die
höchsten Sozialleistungen und deswegen
sind wir auch ein Magnet für viele
Menschen die ein besseres Leben haben
wollen m konsequent die pullfaktoren die
es gibt
abschaffen oder zurückfahren wissen sie
in Hessen habe ich immer drauf
hingewiesen dass die CDU in den Monaten
vor dem Wahlkampf plötzlich das Thema
entdeckt hat wir müssen die
Masseneinwanderung begrenzen und ich
habe immer drauf hingewiesen eine starke
AFD übt Druck aus und deswegen ist eine
Stimme für die AFD eine Stimme die wirkt
und dass sich jetzt auf Bundesebene
etwas bewirkt bewegt das ist zwei
Faktoren geschuldet zum einen dass wir
in der massiven Überforderung sind das
ist ja wirklich beim besten Willen nicht
so weitergeht und zum zweiten AFD wirkt
die starken Wahlergebnisse haben Druck
gemacht dass ich auf Bundesebene jetzt
etwas bewegt ja Sie müssen sich aber
irgendwann an diesen Versprechen die sie
dann damit auch abgeben messen lassen
noch eine eine Sache gerne gerne
verstehen letzter Punkt sie dürfen
sofort Fachkräfte aus Drittländern
würden sie nur im äußersten Fall
anwerben besser Menschen aus Deutschland
kulturell nahestehende Nachbarländern ja
wer ist das das sind Menschen die in
iche Werte vertreten woher kommen die
welche Länder meinen sie das sind in
erster Linie Menschen aus Europa aber
also welche Länder Holländer oder jedes
Land wo Menschen zu uns kommen wollen
aber zur Wahrheit gehört es auch Land
zur Wahrheit gehört es dass wir in den
ganzen Statistiken wo mal bewertet wird
wie attraktiv eigentlich die Länder für
qualifizierte Fachkräfte sind die bereit
in einem Land zu arbeiten dass wir da
relativ weiß unten stehen weil wir haben
mit die höchsten Steuern und Abgaben
weltweit wir haben ein riesen Problem
bezahlbarer Wohnraum wir haben eine hohe
Bürokratie wir haben nicht so starke
Digitalisierung symtombeschreibung und
da haben sie ja auch recht mit dem bef
deswegen müssen wir runter von den hohen
Steuern und Abgaben wir müssen mehr mehr
Digitalisierung umsetzen wir müssen die
Bürokratie reduzieren und das ist dann
auch eine Lösung um z.B Fachkräfte die
auswandern alle ander Parteien auch Herr
lu okay aber das heißt wir halten jetzt
fest mit anderen Worten Robin Alexander
Herr lambru hat keine wirkliche Lösung
nein das stimmt nicht ich habe ein ich
habe Robin Alexander Entschuldigung als
politisch also ich lass jetzt mal ein
paar Sachen einfach durchlaufen die
nicht gestimmt haben bei dem was Sie
gesagt haben aber das lass ich
durchlaufen sind sie ja sauer aber wenn
Sie das sagen mit den Boten ja also die
australische Lösung war Leute sind mit
Boten nach Australien gefahren und die
Australier haben sie auf Insel gebracht
oder nach Kambodscha und so weiter
darüber wird an mehreren Stellen in
Europa nachgedacht die haben z. gesagt
man könnte das in Ruanda machen genau
dies ist aber gescheitert vor einer
britischen Spruchkammer weil es der
Europäischen Menschenrechtskonvention
entspricht kein einziges Flugzeug
Richtung so jetzt kann man darüber
nachdenken ob das vor Gerichten
standhalten könnte wenn man in Ruanda
ordentliche Verfahren machen würde und
das könnte wahrscheinlich nicht die
Regierung in Randa sein aber vielleicht
das un flüchtlingshilfswerk also da gibt
es Ideen und das wird in Europa auch in
diese Richtung gedacht genau und es ist
wirklich nicht so dass ich niemand dafür
interessiert außer die AFD das ich
glauben Sie mir ich habe darüber ein
Buch geschrieben ich habe darüber viel
publiziert Frau Teuteberg hat ihren
Posten als Generalsekretärin unter
anderem deshalb verloren weil sie ihren
Parteivorsitzenden damit auf den Keks
gegangen ist und er hat uns ja schon
erklärt wir jeden Tag versucht die Leute
unterzubringen also dass sie der einzige
sind den das irgendwie bewegt in
Deutschland das stimmt echt nicht habe
ich so nicht gesagt so und das sollten
Sie auch zugestehen und dann warum wir
uns auch in dieser Sendung so gestritten
haben und wo auch wirklich ein Problem
mit der AFD ist sie haben die
prinzipiellen Sachen nicht gerade sie
haben ihr Verhältnis Z deutschen
Vergangenheit nicht gerade sie haben ihr
Verhältnis zu Europa nicht gerade sie
haben ihr Verhältnis zu NATO nicht
gerade sie haben Verhältnis zu Russland
nicht gerade so und deshalb finde ich es
auch zätzend dass sie immer sagen wir
sind die Konservativen und die Linken
glauben das noch das ist ja das Schlimme
also das ist ja anschlussfähig an LS was
sie sagen und das ist nicht konservativ
ein Franz Josef Straus oder ein Adenauer
wusste doch Russland Amerika deutsche
Vergangenheit Brüssel das hätte man die
4 Uhr nachts wecken können und ob man
sie persönlich wecken kann weiß ich
nicht ich sehe sie zum ersten Mal aber
ihre Leute kann man halt in der Fläche
nicht wecken sie sind dann nicht
verlässlich und das sollten Sie
bearbeiten und dann würden wir auch die
sagen immer framen sie meinen wohl
Begriffe überstüben oder was meinen Sie
damit aber ich lese ihn ihr Programm vor
ich meine womit soll ich sie
konfrontieren wenn ich im eigene
Programm und sie nehmen unser
eu-wahlprogramm nicht zur kennnis weil
es ihnen nicht in den Kram passt doch
auch da ja
aber nehmen Sie doch die Kritik mal an
schauen Sie ich habe das Recht eine
andere Meinung zu haben und ich weise
auf einen Umstand hin wir haben gerade
erst vor ein paar Tagen hier in Hessen
mit unserem Programm mit unserer Art wie
wir auftreten das beste Ergebnis der AFD
jemals in Westdeutschland geholt viele
Menschen sind der Meinung dass es a
nicht so weitergeht und B die AFD Teil
der Lösung ist mM das ist aber sozusagen
dagegen sein aus Prinzip wir sind nicht
protestin dokumentieren dass man das so
nicht mehr möchte aber ich habe versucht
einen konstruktiven Ansatz irgendwo zu
finden ich mir ist aber bis jetzt leider
entgangen Herr LZ darf ich noch eines
kurz sagen dürfen sie die Umfragen
zeigen ganz klar dass uns viele Menschen
aus Überzeugung wählen für unser
inhaltliches Programm undter stehen zu
gesellschaftspolitischen Bereichen Ideen
und Lösungen
drin kann man nachlesen Frau torteberg
sie wollten bit da bitte um kurze
Antwort ja also eine kurze Vorbemerkung
die mir wichtig ist sie habmer die Frage
aufgeworfen ich finde man muss ganz
klipp und klar sagen die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland profitiert massiv von dieser
Europäischen Union und zwar sowohl von
dem Binnenmarkt aber auch als
Friedensprojekt die ganze Freizügigkeit
die will ich auch erhalten die wollen
Freie Demokraten erhalten gerade deshalb
ist unter anderem wirksamer
außengrenzschutz wichtig und es ist kein
entweder oder wir müssen in Deutschland
unsere Hausaufgaben machen dazu gehören
viele Dinge tatsächlich pullfaktoren
reduzieren bessere Verfahren schnellere
Verfahren aber eben auch und das ist mir
wichtig weil wir Europa tatsächlich
zusammenhalten wollen wir sollten auch
migrationspolitisch mal diese zeitenwend
hinbekommen z.B unvereingenommen mit
unseren Partnern reden dass z.B Polen
und Tschechien sehr viele Ukrainer
aufgenommen haben relativ zu ihrer Größe
und Wirtschaftskraft sogar noch mehr als
Deutschland zeigt ja auch dass die
Plausibilität des fluchtgrundes auch ein
großer Faktor für die Akzeptanz ist und
für die hilfs- und Aufnahmebereitschaft
und deshalb ist mir so wichtig dass wir
wirklich daran arbeiten möglichst Fehre
Vorprüfung schon vor den Außengrenzen
hinzubekommen weil wir diejenigen die
bereit sind in Europa Verantwortung zu
übernehmen auch nur überzeugen werden
wenn wir tatsächlich nicht von einer
unbegrenzten Zahl von möglicherweise
auch überwiegend nicht
schutzberechtigten sondern von einer
rechtsstaatlich geprüften Zahl von
Menschen die tatsächlich auch nach
unseren Standards die wir europäisch
teil schutzberechtigt sind erst dann
werden wir da gemeinsame Lösungen
hinbekommen und nicht mit dieser
unpolitischen Unbedingtheit mit der
bisher so ein deutscher Sonderweg
betrieben wurde sondern ich glaube dass
wir na einen Konsens darüber dass wir
Kontrolle darüber gewinnen wollen dass
in der Regel Menschen mit einer
bleiibeperspektive mit einem
Schutzanspruch nur nach Europa einreisen
dürfen dass wir dann da auch eher zu
europäischen Lösung kommen und die
brauchen wir um unsere Demokratie in
Deutschland wie in Europa
zusammenzuhalten weil mir reicht es
nicht in Sonntagsreden Z sagen unser
Grundgesetz gilt ich denke z.B an die
Lehrerinnen und Lehrer oder die
PolizistInnen oder Polizisten die in
Neuköln jeden Tag dafür sorgen müssen
dass das gilt und wie es denen geht wenn
sie z.B bei konsequentem Vorgehen gegen
Antisemitismus sich auch noch m
rassismusverdacht ausgesetzt sehen also
die Dinge sind sehr kompliziert und umso
mehr müssen wir daran sehr ernsthaft
arbeiten aber gerade weil wir die
liberale offene Gesellschaft erhalten
wollen deshalb ist mir das wichtig